Ah-trolls the Internet whether it's on Twitter, a forum, or even these comments in YouTube
It does not seem that we can escape from them .... But who are these people? - And how do they look? When evaluated in a scientific sense
While many people enjoy chatting and chatting on the Internet, nearly 5.6% of individuals
They know themselves as trolls, or they like phishing online. So scientists decided
Study a group of 1200 Internet users to understand these trolls where they found countless
Of the so-called "dark qualities". Specifically found that trolls show high levels of
Mental disorders, narcissism and specifically sadism are people who enjoy the pain of others
Now, most people tend to avoid hurting others, and if we do, we suffer from guilt
Or reprimand of the conscience, but for the masters, cruelty can be exciting and enjoyable for these people
They do not necessarily have to be thugs or bad people but get emotional rewards when they are
They cause or monitor the suffering of others. In fact, so that there is a class called
"Sadism Daily" which highlights how there are sadistic qualities in many people
- Not just sexual predators or criminals, for example, many of us have a good fight
During sports or excitement from a thrilling movie, right?
If you choose between the following four jobs, which one will you choose?
A) kill insects b) help someone being experienced in killing insects c) cleaning dirty toilets or d) carrying pain
Of ice water? Studies indicate that those who chose to kill insects have the highest points in
The range of sadistic pulse measurement.
But Internet trolls are showing very high levels of sadism in finding pleasure in others' sorrows
While they are controversial and argumentative, studies have also documented a link between
Individuals and anti-social behavior. So are these individuals different in real life?
It is unlikely - studies indicate that these traits are regularly transmitted to them from day to day
And reflect one's actual personality. But while the Internet provides the property of anonymity
Anti-social individuals can communicate with others in a similar way while disassociating themselves from their actions
In terms of personal responsibility.
The unfortunate part is that trolls are not only more attached than they get more responses than
For the average user, indicating that they are adept at luring others - moreover
Negative feedback only works to stimulate the offending responses of the trolls
Their behavior becomes worse over time with more feedback.
So, next time if you bully someone just remember they want to block you
And feed on your unhappiness. Ignoring them is likely to reduce their efforts
Need more science? Here is a playlist of our latest videos that you can borrows an hour.
And if you do not want to miss our videos, simply go to our channel on your device
YouTube app and a small bell hit that turns on notifications of our videos. Youtube
We will send you a message each time we launch a video.
Subscribe to get more weekly flag videos!
Translate to English